we are here to document the lives of
people living in Alaska the harsh
reality is the environment we're up
against it makes it tough to do our job
they're working on life below zero can
be very dangerous guns here cameras here
never know what to expect you see that
gonna be tough but we're gonna get the
shot every scenario we got to prepare
for this but we're still smiling or
having fun still making like below zero
yeah bring it on
so of all the things that we do working
on life below zero I would say this is
one of the most challenging it's our
travel day to the hailstones koala camp
the biggest challenge is getting out
there we can only get to about a hundred
miles away from where we're going by
plane and then the rest of the way we
need to go on snow machines hauling
sleds with some of our gear we are right
at the edge of the peninsula so we'll be
traveling over sea ice for the next
forty miles the ice is very dynamic out
here on the ocean it's breaking and
coming together let's be moved by the
tides and by the wind and it's a little
bit dangerous but we've mitigate those
dangers by making a good plan and taking
our time and being thoughtful about how
we travel so we're right on target we've
got a couple hours of daylight left and
it looks like we should be fine to get
into camp and make some shelter before
it's totally dark it's incredible that
we get to do this so this is our job
riding across the Arctic Ocean we're
really feeling lucky right now
we arrived here just before dark last
night after our 100-mile trip so when we
got in last night was all we could do to
just get shelter up basically and get
the things that we needed to get a
decent night's sleep we've got a home
that's relatively comfortable relatively
warm now it's time to organize and
settle in so that we can be ready for
filming anyone that works on this show
you can't be complacent you need to
prepare properly every time you go in
something bad could happen you don't
want to be out there in a sticky
situation here we are in Deadhorse
inside the hangar we're going into kavik
- hasn't been that kavik for quite a bit
of time so we're gonna go in planning
for the worst hoping for the best when
we get there we have quite a bit of
camera equipment here a show like life
below zero requires us to travel with a
lot of gear this isn't your standard
show where you can drive in a car get to
set and start shooting we're going in
not knowing what we're gonna get into so
we go as prepared as possible we're
heading in and we're actually hitting
them with sue this is her first time
going back in months we don't know what
to expect at camp so we've got full
GoPros rigged my focus as always I'm
trying to capture what we expect to see
and that is going to be we're going to
be flying over the camp to check it out
so we've got a camera looking down
camera on the wing looking at her and
she's driving and then obviously her as
she's looking out the window we can't
get in there so it's just gonna be
GoPros
we just joy the ride our number one
concern is safety everything is safe and
everyone is safe
doing our work personal gears over here
guys so we're going out to Andy bass at
this place I'm really excited to go out
there there's a lot of logistics
involved with get into Candis
we start in Fairbanks we fly to Eagle on
a small plane and then they basically we
put all of our stuff here and then we
get on even smaller plane and then we
just do multiple trips for about five or
six hours until everything's out there
let me get on snow machines sleds and we
basically haul everything to our cabins
to get set up but the main thing here is
that when you're filming people living
off the grid we have to live off the
grid to in order to really capture that
story we have to live that life so right
here we basically have all of our food
items our camera gear fuel here for
cooking we're in a very remote place we
kind of have to be self sustainable from
the beginning oh man tiny smaller than
the outhouse I'm going to be using
[Music]
it's a very windy area there's a lot of
mountain terrain there's low trees and
then he basically has to make a perfect
landing on this lake and it's just
complete glare right so it's a really
bumpy landing but we're here and the
real work begins the way we get the true
story we're not living in a hotel I mean
we are literally in a remote place and
in order to capture that true story we
have to live that lifestyle - time to go
live off the grid for a little bit
[Music]